Speaker 1: Radical and repugnant. Congresswoman
Lauren Boebert is now openly trying to destroy
the Constitution, the very constitution
that she claims to love, that she claims to
treat almost as if it were a sacred text or a
religious doctrine of sorts. She now wants pastors
to preach how churches can influence the
direction of government. Now understand that
in order to be nonprofit entities and not pay all
sorts of different taxes, churches actually have
to avoid politics altogether. And what Lauren
Boebert is suggesting is not just that churches
get involved in politics, but that churches
actually get directly involved in trying to
influence government rather than just their
parishioners or the people attending their
church services. And this is the second time in
three weeks that Lauren Boebert is openly hostile
to separation of church and state, enshrined by
the Constitution and Bill of Rights. And they
will often not even justify it in any real way.
Occasionally they will say, you know, the founding
fathers were Christian, so therefore we don't need
separation of church and state. Well, they may
have been some of them anyway, but they recognized
the importance of that being their personal set of
beliefs and not part of civil government. So let's
get into the first clip here. Lauren Boebert says
We need churches influencing government. Sorry,
Lauren. That's not what the Constitution says.
Speaker 3: And I believe that great patriots
all throughout this nation and Christians
will begin to position themselves in
these days and these times that pastors
we have a pulpit to speak from the pulpit of
their churches to direct and inform the church
on how to influence the direction of government.
Speaker 1: And that is the opposite of what the
Constitution says needs to be the way
the country is organized. And in fact,
we already have. I mean, the sad reality is, much
like the checks and balances that Trump ignored
and seems to have successfully ignored,
at least for now, in terms of consequences
in theory, when churches do politics, they lose
their tax exempt status in practice. I've been
covering for close to two decades churches that
do politics, and we almost never see them lose
their tax exempt status. So both what Lauren
Boebert is saying is both completely against
both the Constitution and the tax code and will
probably get away with it because there is very
limited willingness or resources among the IRS
to actually police this now. This is not a new
thing with Lauren Boebert. This is Lauren Boebert
new calling. She recently again in the trend of
trashing the very constitution that she claims
to revere. She said she's tired of separation
of church and state. She called it junk. In fact.
Speaker 3: The reason we had so many overreaching
regulations in our nation is
because the church complied.
The church is supposed to direct the government.
The government is not supposed to direct the
church. That is not how our Founding Fathers
intended it. And I'm tired of the separation
of church and state junk that's not in the
Constitution. It was in a stinking letter,
and it means nothing like what they say it does.
Speaker 1: So that is open hostility, open
hostility to what is actually in the Constitution.
Now, of course, the establishment clause is where
we see that enshrined. Congress shall make no
law respecting an establishment of religion. That
also means putting the non-religious at any kind
of disadvantage one way or the other. And the.
Founding Fathers seemed better. Not that they
were perfect at separating their personal beliefs
from what should be the role of religion in
government. When they talk about, you know,
they they it is true. When they when she refers
to a letter, she's talking about Thomas Jefferson.
Thomas Jefferson is maybe responsible for the
most famous use of the metaphor for separation
of church and state. From a letter where he talks
about a wall of separation. And the new thing that
Republicans love to do is to say it's not really
in the Constitution. It was just in a letter that
Jefferson wrote. But. First of all, the letters
are relevant in telling us the intent of the
founding fathers here at James Madison. Also in in
private, what we would call private communications
made clear that any government involvement
in religion or support for any particular
religion or even the placing in a preferred
status of religion over non religion would
be improper and inappropriate for government.
And also you have the establishment clause. So
as often is the case, oh, Democrats are going to
try to steal the election and use fraud and all
this. But actually they did it. They that they're
actually the ones that that did that thing.
Whenever they point to something, we should be
wondering, are they actually the ones doing it?
And when they say the left is destroying the
Constitution and wants to use it as toilet
paper or whatever the case may be, we should be
wondering whether whether it is actually they
who are trying to do that. And that is exactly
what Lauren Boebert is trying to do. Now,
to their credit, there are some more mainstream
Republicans, Mitt Romney, for example, who
doesn't agree with this perspective. He is, as
far as I have most recently seen for Mitt Romney,
he is personally very religious, he's Mormon
and on and on. But he would take issue with what
Lauren Boebert says in this clip. Many other
Republicans won't support it publicly, but
they like what she's saying, so they'll just shut
their mouths. And then you have the ones that are
just full throated for full throated endorsers of
what Lauren Boebert is saying. And it's dangerous.
And if they end up getting more power, whether
it's the House, Senate, more governorships at
the state level, they will try to make this
establishment of Christianity in government
even more of a reality than it already is, because
to some degree it already is there. Which religion
gets federal holidays? Just Christianity, right?
I mean, Easter and Christmas. There's there's no
other religion that gets federal holidays and
so many other things that we've talked about.
Ten Commandments displays at courthouses
and on and on and on. It will get worse.